ربما يكون هذا النوع من الروبوتات عاديه
للكثيرين لكن يبدو ان المشهد في قطاع
التكنولوجيا يشهد تغيرات متسارعه مع اطلاق
الروبوتشات جي بي تي
فهذا الروبوت الذي ابتكرته شركه اوبن اي
اي لابحث الذكاء الاصطناعي يتمثل في شكل
تطبيق يتمتع بقدرات غير مسبقه فهذا
الروبوت يستطيع الاجابه عن اي اسئله توجه
اليه في مختلف المجالات الاجتماعيه
والسياسيه والاقتصاديه والهندسيه والطبيه
وغيرها كما يسمح هذا الروبوت بتصحيح ما
يكتبه اذا اخطا بل ويعتذر عن تلك الاخطاء
النصوص البشريه من خلال الذكاء الاصطناعي
كما يمكنه تحرير عدد هائل من البيانات
ويعمل بصوره تشبه الدماغ البشريه اكثر من
ذلك يمكن استخدامه دون اتصالي بشبكه
الانترنت وان كان يتم دوما تغذيته بمزيد
من البيانات في كل المجالات
لكن تم تتساؤلات الجوهريه عن مدى تاثير
الذكاء الاصطناعي على اعمال البشر بدايه
هناك وظائف عالميه قد تستفيدوا من هذا
الذكاء الاصطناعي وتشمل خدمه العملاء من
خلال التواصل معهم ومحاوله حل مشكلاتهم
البرمجه بكل انواعها وقطاع الاعلانات
واعمال
انا ابحث اجرتها مصادر وصفتها بالموثقه
تتنبا بان الذكاء الاصطناعي قد يستحدثوا
على وظائف يعملوا بها نحو مليار شخص على
مستوى العالم خلال السنوات ال 10 المقبله
واضافت المجله ان هذا القمر قد يؤدي الى
الغاء نحو
375 مليون وظيفه يبدو ان شركه مايكروسوفت
لافاق المستقبل واعد ضدك الاصطناعي فقررت
تعزيز الشراكاتها معه
تقدر بعشره مليارات دولار خلال السنوات
القليله المقبله
ويتمثل احد مجالات الاستخدام المحتمله
لتشارجي ان يصبح بديل لمحركات البحث
وابرزه جوجل وتفيد صحيفه نيويورك
تهدد ارادتك جوجل التي بلغت نحو 2007 257
مليار دولار عام 2021 لكن في المقابل يقول
باستخدمنا لهذا الروبوت من المعلومات التي
يذكرها تبدو ذكيه لكنها في بعض احيان
خاطئه او تفتقر الى الدقه
ولهذا تؤكد شركه اوبن اي اي انها ترغب في
معرفه اراء المستخدمين والتقييماتهم لكي
تتمكن من تحسين اداء هذا الروبوت